[Music]
coming into this segment because this
morning we are looking at rudeness in
the workplace as part of our series with
LinkedIn called
work in progress an estimated 98% of
employees deal with difficult people at
work new research from Harvard Business
Review shows victims of rudeness are the
ones being blamed it also found managers
perceive those victims to be worse
performers on the job than employees who
had not been mistreated regardless of
their actual performance so link pins
editor-in-chief Dan Roth is here with
stories from LinkedIn and the impact of
rude behavior at work good to see you
thanks for having me here so Dan explain
to me why our managers blaming those
employees who actually report that
people are being rude to them I think it
is first of all it's not surprising the
people are being rude to each other in
the office we are rude to each other all
the time everywhere it's hard it's hard
and but in the workplace what what
really breaks people we start out the
conversation about this on LinkedIn
people started weighing in and they
didn't mind that they knew that people
were gonna be rude what really broke
them what kind of sent them into tears
and have health issues is when they
reported to their managers and the
managers came back and said you're the
problem and I think this happens because
number one you got to make your numbers
number two you are just trying to get
through the day and someone comes to you
and says this person is causing me a
problem managers say like I don't have
time for this I don't really want to
deal with it yeah you deal with it
please let me do my job
yeah so that's one big thing the other
thing in this and the study they say
this is that if the manager is friends
with the person who is being accused of
the bully in the office or rude your
complaint will go absolutely nowhere you
have no shot and we kept hearing story
after story of people saying this
happened to them and they had just
checked out they were not gonna pay
attention to work anymore
I'm literally counseling someone on this
right now so what is the effective way
to deal with rudeness in the workplace
number one you if the more you can try
to just move on past it you you can if
you are or leave that company the key is
being in a workplace culture where they
actually support you for this and some
of the best companies will do things
like have a third party come in
and evaluate what's going on so that you
don't have these kind of interpersonal
conflicts interpersonal relationships
that could change how you view the
person who's reporting the problem
what's the impact on the company itself
in the circumstance oh look it is a
incredibly tight labor market we know
that 70% of workers say they will not
work in a place that has a bad corporate
culture yeah you are losing your best
talent if you have a culture like this
people who eat if they're not quitting
they're checking out and what you don't
want is a bunch of unproductive people
who are coming in who are miserable at
work and just collecting a paycheck and
getting out of there you can't stay
competitive if you do that so managers
out there if you're listening and now
you're aware yeah what should they do
that's a great question there's training
that you can do you can learn to be more
judicial and the authors in this study
talk about this judges have to go
through training to learn how to listen
to complaints and not take it personally
and think through what the problem is
it's worth doing training an executive
from PwC wrote in and said we do AI
training AI and virtual reality training
to just help people through tough help
managers I deal with tough situations
and learn how to process these
complaints you know what to do about it
so if you're running a company you got
to put in processes and training to get
your managers to understand how to
listen to these complaints and not just
blow them off or blame the victim
there's way to report a technology then
contributing to the rude behavior I
think this is probably always been going
on I would say that technology bike I do
it only because there is so much more
competition now as technology makes it
easier to compete against everyone and
compete globally these companies are
facing new competitors and new ways and
they have to move faster all the time
and cut costs and so if your managers
you don't want to deal with it it costs
money and time to deal with this but two
people don't know how to talk to one
another anymore because they're there
they are there they're communicating
with these now yeah although were
they're being rude on those things
tweets yeah media rude emails yes I
would rather have them you know looking
on their phone and checking videos than
yelling at me in the office so the other
hand if I K go post somewhere else
instead of instead of yelling at me or
disrespecting me I'll take that all
right never happened to the Golden Rule
oh there it is that's what I keep on my
desk do unto others advantages where
duty a damn rod thank you thank you